[Music]
samuel leeds is britain's most notorious
multi-millionaire property investor
best-selling author and founder of a
leading property education company
with hundreds of success students
carving their way to financial freedom
using his cutting-edge strategies
samuel is regarded as the ultimate
renegade property investor
in this year's eviction the stakes have
been raised big time
with the winner receiving the keys to
the kingdom by getting a life-changing
prize
of a whole week's one-to-one mentoring
in their own
financial freedom challenge more drama
more heartbreak and more action as
candidates battle it out to be the 2020
winner of
the eviction we had over 500 people
applied to be on the eviction
we've got 10 candidates that are part of
the process
let's see what happens this is crazy
you're evicted
hi my name is lawson hopwood and i'm a
senior account manager from manchester
my name is david eckles i'm from ireland
my name is oia mcbay
i am from london my name is anisia
hutchinson
i'm 18 years old and i'm from london
originally but raised in warsaw
my name is evan swilley i'm from elin my
name's nadia
i'm 39 years old i'm originally from
manchester
hi my name's endrit i'm 21 years old i'm
a property sourcer
based in london hello my name is jaden
and i'm 20 years old i'm from east
london i'm jamal robinson i'm 21 from
sheffield hi i'm faz
i'm 30 years old i'm from coventry so as
i mentioned i'm a senior account manager
but recently made redundant during
lockdown and found that property was
almost my way out so it was a blessing
in disguise being made redundant has
allowed me to push full time
in property deal sourcing and being able
to jump onto this competition
i wanted to join this competition
because i really want to make a
statement and just show it in the video
it doesn't really matter where you came
from um as long as you really want it
bad enough you'll do whatever it takes
to get it my last name is willie and i'm
doing this to
you know really put my last name out
there so let's go team will it
um in terms of my academics i feel like
i've always been someone who did well at
school
i was head girl in primary school i was
on the school council in secondary
school
i did pretty well in school and then
went on to get a grad job as well um
in a top four um accountancy firm in
canary wharf
um so things have kind of like fallen
into place in terms of like academics
and
my career and profession dream life will
be a life where
i'm happy and i can do what one i kind
of like
i associated happiness with money
my whole life because i thought the
reason why in my life is so sad the
reason why my mum's always
upset or always struggling is because i
don't have money and
like it was just like money equaled
happiness to me
and i don't and the more that i grow and
the more that i evolve
i realize money doesn't actually equal
happiness it really doesn't
what equals happiness is freedom i've
always known that i don't want a job i
don't want to work for anyone like that
i got into a state agency i did that for
a few months
but i went really enjoying that as well
but then around that same time that's
when i discovered samuel
and started watching his videos and
stuff and then i got into serviced
accommodation
i wanted to join this competition
because i want to give back
i want to help others i want to show my
son
that anything that you believe that you
can do you can do it i want to learn
from
samuel because he's the best in the uk
i've
researched and seen he he is the best
maybe the accent some people don't
we need subtitles
[Laughter]
i'm like a strong competitor so i don't
like losing this
this is all i ever wanted to do is
property so
never went to college yeah so to get
into the eviction
what i'd done was i've made a post about
samuel leads i've posted it on youtube
instagram facebook twitter everything i
could think of
i messaged everyone i know and random
people as well to tag samuel leeds
i got about 160 messages tagging samuel
leeds so he kept seeing my name pop up
my why is for my father i've seen him
work for so many years
i've seen him he's a really hard worker
but i want to give him some free time
i want to make him financially free my
dream life looks like
financially free my circle around me
financially free
my family financially free um 2020 has
been very interesting because
went from like start of january
was at um uni doing sound engineering
didn't really like it it wasn't for me
stuck in the classroom ended up dropping
out of uni
even in my house everyone just being
entrepreneurial in a way
like without selling stuff or whether it
was got a podcast or got a youtube
channel everyone's just doing something
entrepreneurial
so i was working the call center for
five years
and it's just not it wasn't for me i
quit my job
and all i thought at the time was to get
into a trade was very successful
um i didn't know at the time anything
about property
so i got into a trade as electrician one
day i put the lockout system on the
electrics locked it out put a sign on it
saying i'm using the electrics i'm
currently working on it
i went up some ladders on the roof and
there was a wire that i was rewiring and
then another electrician came in
this this disregarded the tag that i put
on the electric box
cut the bolt turn the electrics back on
when i was at the ladders
it electrocuted me in the head there was
a wireless my head sent me off i fell
off the ladders
off the roof of the house onto the floor
electrocuted myself and
hurt my back severely and it put me at
work for about four years
and during that time when i was out of
work that's really when i
realized when i stopped the money stops
and i need to change your career
i'm the underdog i'm the person that
meant to go home first
and i'm still going to be here at the
very last stage smiling
you calculate the roi by the total
amount invested by
the amount that you're getting out
divided by 100
times 100 sorry just everything in
general added in
minus uh let's see i missed
i know what i'm saying but i messed it
up can i start again
article 4 came in to be honest i'm not
exactly sure the date
um but i don't think it's too long ago i
think 2018 that might be wrong
a mortgage is wait i think it's the
amount of money put in divided by
no something divided by total investment
that's not clear
um i think it's 24. wait
roi is um
yield is no idea i'm gonna lie i would
probably
say
roi is
[Music]
a mortgage a mortgage is a loan
on a property i believe
can i take a rough guess camera pressure
i know what roi is
return on investment so that's the money
the profit per year um divided by
the value of the property
[Music]
50 million oh no clue 50 million
ounces in the uk house in the uk there's
around 20 to 25
000. roi's returning investment that's
when
you find out how much money goes into
the deal how much you get out of the
deal
you take the annual rent profit and then
you divide it by
the total money down for the deal yeah
they get roi in times of 100
well them lot clearly had absolutely no
idea what they're on about yes the
eviction is back with a brand new series
and thankfully samuel leeds is here to
give us a mystic meg look back at what's
happened this year in property the year
2020 has been an
absolutely crazy year loads of people
are losing their jobs they've been made
redundant
and right now more than ever i think
people need to become property
entrepreneurs i had the idea for the
eviction
in summer 2020 and we were kind of
coming out a lockdown by then so i
thought by the end of the year when we
do it
it's going to be great it's going to be
perfect we're going to spend a whole
month
living in my house it's gonna be awesome
challenges
and we can evict people slowly but what
happened was the restrictions
with the pandemic got more and more
tight and it was actually just
days before we met with the ten
contestants
when we were told we were about to go
into a second nation
wide lockdown and everyone's telling me
all my team and the executives on the
board
samuel we need to cancel the eviction
it's cancelled it's cancelled
i'm thinking but these 10 candidates a
lot of them have been made redundant
they've lost
their jobs they need a break so i didn't
know what to do
and it was literally 10 minutes
before they all turned up they turned up
at a hotel
they thought that they were going ahead
with the eviction my staff thought that
it was being cancelled
and 10 minutes prior to speaking to them
i thought i'm not telling them it's
cancelled
we're going to run with this we're going
to condense it the first challenge it
was supposed to take a week we're going
to have to do in a night
and we suddenly just the videographers
came from everywhere we condensed it and
we got started there and then on the
spot
impromptu which was just amazing before
the first challenge was set
the week prior i met with all of the
candidates and i told them your first
challenge is going to be around buy
refurbished refinance deals
so i gave them all the online buy
refurbished refinance masterclass which
by the way
is a 1 000 course and they were all so
happy they said thank you
i said is everyone got time to do the
course this week they all said yes
so they knew that by the time we met for
the first challenge
they had to have completed that training
so when we met up for the first
challenge
i set them a challenge where they had to
find a buy refurbished refinance
opportunity
on the spot and i told them had 10
minutes to do that
and to be honest from the training that
they'd had the week prior most people
should be able to find a property
opportunity
so let's see you had a had a pretty big
challenge last was it was it a week ago
when we met and you had the buy
refurbished refinance master class given
to you guys was
did you get on well with the trainer
excellent fantastic
uh good to see you all so it starts now
you know literally we begin right now no
messing it's happening
we're on the challenge today is going to
be around brr by the way
so hence why you have the the homework
to go through the brr master class one
of you
very very very soon is going to be
selected as the winner of the eviction
and the winner of the eviction isn't
going to get a a certificate of
well done you graduated you're the
winner you're not going to get an
accreditation scheme
you're going to get to do an ff
challenge with me i want to be living
with somebody
that actually takes action someone that
gets results someone that can learn
quick
someone that arrives on time so the
first challenge
is is going to be to find a brr lead
that's going to be the first challenge
now you've all got iphones you've got
laptops i want you to find
and be prepared to present maybe to me
maybe to the room
your brr deal 10 minutes begins
now so here we go the candidates begin
scouring the internet to find a buy
refurbished refinance property if you
don't know what this means essentially
it's finding a rundown property for mega
cheap which needs loads of work doing on
it
the idea is to buy it cheap uplift the
value by renovating it to a whole new
level of swanky gorgeousness
and getting a revaluation done to
realize it's worth way more
if you do it really well you can pull
all of your money back out and move on
to the next one
come on jayden come on out come on out
give jaden a hand give him a hand
all right excellent all right um i've
got a deal in
i'm missing ws10 you need to put 32
500 down sorry so how much did you put
down thirty thousand five hundred
thirty thousand that's just um 25
deposit
and then with the refurb that's going to
come to 49 500.
am i the only one who noticed how short
his trouser legs are
around 375.5 per room all right and
what's the
cost of the refurb and how did you come
to that figure of course it's 17 000
because i roster workout and from the
the um also called the refurbishment
sheet we got from before
um i worked out that he needs a lot of
whole new carpet whole new kitchen
that's around four thousand
so i'm looking at it now that looks
realistic alistair there looking as
engaged as usual
just found it right now okay and the uh
the gdv
what's the end value end value um
i didn't get to check that bit but yeah
and you guys check that but
okay you do realize that the property
has sold
oh dear well this is awkward jayden
isn't it no i don't realize that
i really wanted you all to be at a point
where you could find at least a half
decent brr deal
and not even knowing having any idea
what the end value is
is a little bit concerning okay cool all
right who's next excellent
go for it then david embrace the asking
is 55 000 pounds yeah i
was trying to be conservative of the
reefer i estimated
a referral of 15 000 which was taken
a total to 70 thousand pound and
[Music]
david looks like a completely overworked
labour politician knocking on your front
door to try and get your vote
because i was going to do a printing
your 63
750 and the trouble
and 55 thousand plus fifteen
was seven thousand pounds so
that was being conservative there's a
chance to pull all the money out but
going off that
i was leaving and uh
what did you say was the end value i
went for 85 000 just in the middle
where did you get your end value from
based on what there is
i didn't get sounds extreme most price
but when you went to nearby soil prices
of true property sold on that same
street for
80 000. yeah i can see them it looks
good
great you can go grab a seat go ahead
we've got a three bed
uh terrace house it's actually an
auction
probably it says a silver auction with a
style bid 50 grand
it needs quite a lot of work doing
there's a full cosmetic referral
but being quite conservative i've said
if the bid goes up to let's say 70k
which is realistic for the condition of
it
and including legal fees and stuff uh
the total money in
would be about 85 grand so you're saying
you're buying it for 50 and then you're
spending 35 grand doing it
but looking at the other houses in the
area i reckon it would be
it'd go for highway okay so you buy it
for 70 what do you reckon the
development cost will be
about 10 and what's the gdv so
the gdp based on other assault
properties in the area on the actual
same road
um in the last eight years
uh three are sold one for 120k one for
125 and one for 110
so our total money is 85
but i've gone for the end value of 110
okay
so once we get a mortgage on that 75
lots of volume that'll be 82 500.
so um we'll be left with 2500 left in
the deal
and what did you value your 110 end
value on
based on what other properties were sold
in the
is this one that you found prior or did
you find this just now
just now is there any questions do you
know what number what house number is
that
okay so you it's all it's starting
starting bid of 50 000 pounds
um what costs would you be needed to pay
at the auction house
when you uh when the hammer falls the
cost of the box
okay because obviously you need to
factor that in anyone that's doing
auction properties you need to factor
that in and typically it would be at
least 10
on top of that so if you're saying
you're going to buy at 70 000
you'll probably end up um i i
predict that i'll actually go for more
than that if you put forward an offer
at pre-auction and it was rejected hi
girls based on the training that you did
on the brr master class how would you
deal with that
how are you going to turn i i know into
a yes
because obviously that's a massive part
of part of doing deals
is turning those into yeses we spent
quite a long time about it on training
so how would you turn a no into a yes i
think i would
probably plug my bid a bit and so what
volume went out to
how can you up your bid because when
you're putting a bid in an auction you
always start with your highest bid
so how can you up your bid did you
did you finish the training did you
finish
last week yeah you haven't finished it
okay
how come
okay look it's really tough for me but
if you haven't finished the training and
you don't know basic information about
brr
when that was your week's challenge it's
tough for me
dude with regret you're evicted so after
failing to do his homework because the
dog-eater or summit we lose our first
candidate of this year's eviction hi
um
which is not too far so i have an idea
of the area so it's cash only
um it's up for 69 000 at the moment but
it has been up since
june 2018 so i reckon if i am to speak
to
the estate agents or whoever said in it
that we could get some discount on that
potentially like 10k 10 to 20k off it's
a free bed with two receptions so what
i'll do is turn one of the receptions
into a room
make it a four bed um i looked at the
how much it goes for on a spare room
hatch the rooms in
wolverhampton platform and they're
around 350 to 400
per month um so time's up by five
and that gives me about two thousand to
take home a month
um in terms of estimated refurbishment
costs
i literally recently got my bathroom as
well so i know that
um who would actually do it in the
region of 3 to 4k for me
and stay in the kitchen 5k and
in terms of the paint and carpet and
just to kind of
keep it uniform around the house around
three to four
five k so i put an estimated
refurbishment cost
of around 13k i did look at some of the
house prices that went in about 2018 and
they were they
sold for about 80k 90k do you know the
difference between the asking price the
purchase price and the guide price so
the asking price is what the seller was
asking for
um the guide price is kind of the region
that you can get within it could be
between
it could be a 20k margin or whatever and
the
so asking price guide price and purchase
price
and um i think there's a certain amount
that the seller will never go below
um and so that believes the purchase
price
so so the asking price is what they want
the guide price is roughly what they
want and the purchase price
i i i don't it doesn't seem like you
even know the difference
between the guard price the asking price
and the purchase price
let me try and explain that again
because the guard price is 69 nine fifth
day but you're saying you
you can you could buy it for 55 which i
don't think will be possible
but i'm trying to work out your
rationale behind that okay so
sometimes it's prices starting from and
i know that you know
very hard to get the price less than
that yeah whereas on the guide price i
feel like it's um
it's almost like a bracket so you can
have maybe 5k less or 5k more it's yeah
what what bracket is it that because
this is an auction property
the guide price is 69.95 day there's a
very clear percentage
between because if they advertise it for
a certain guide price
they can't they can't advertise it at 69
950 but have an asking price that's way
off
there is a specific percentage do you
know what that percentage is
um i think it's ten percent yeah
it was i guess
okay did you go through all the training
i didn't go through all the training
i had like like one bit left to finish
but i went from the majority
did you find any other deals while you
were going about your your
training um no i didn't i didn't
actually find any other deals
i mean i've got to say i'm a bit
disappointed didn't finish the training
it's not that much training to do
and you had a week to do it in
preparation for a brr challenge
to not do the training you're almost
taking yourself out the game
i mean help me out um i
can only apologize my plan was to finish
the training today i thought starting
the
course tomorrow i spent every single day
even though this was my last week
every single day training after work um
just so that i can have
it doesn't look good it doesn't look
good however sam your bit of sexual
discrimination
you can't get rid of that last lad for
not finishing the course but keep her on
for doing exactly the same bloody thing
337 is not near two or three it's 337. i
just wonder what happened
but it wasn't it was 337.
yeah all i'm thinking is when we do the
ff challenge
the amount of viewings that we're having
to do it's like here there
bang boof drive over to this place to be
to be late
for the first appointment when you've
come from home and you've had a week to
prepare
freaks me out yeah i know that being
late um
it really is a bad impression but it was
it wasn't
out of my control because i should have
probably came down before we got
familiar with
underground and stuff like that but i
was just like it just looks terrible
it looks terrible and and for me having
to go and live with somebody for a week
and do loads of viewings and to be
back-to-back appointments
when you've had a week
anyway not good luck but go on come on
just
speak about that again obviously i've
been up from very early i come from
birmingham i've traveled three hours to
get here the reason why i'm late
is because obviously i've got a wrong on
demand
whether it's your fault or not it
doesn't matter
the point is when we're doing business
we're going out
not from birmingham much further than
that yesterday i was in liverpool
i i went to liverpool i had a 20 minute
appointment if i'd have been five ten
minutes left i missed the appointment
how did you get there
i went by my car
it's gonna be very tough working
together so you're evicted
because because i can't see it working
out this feels less like a tv show more
like a school teacher rollicking his
students for turning up late and not
doing their own work
it's a four bedroom flat it's currently
been advertised for financial
advisors so to get a compliance and get
it up to par i've put us at about 15
right okay so it's on the market for 340
and you're thinking you'll be able to
buy it for how much
300 because it says offers in region off
all right fine okay so go ahead tell me
tell me tell me about the deal
on that street there's there's been a
few properties sold
for 335 um
but not one of them are four beds so
looking at four beds in that area it
realistically was about 395 400
420 yeah um did you just find this now
or did you find this in your training
so no i actually found this in my
training okay so it's on for 340 you're
trying to get it for 300
100 years left on the lease good how
much is going to be the total
um development on it gdp uh no sorry the
total development on it the
refurbishment cost uh
15 and what do you think the gdp would
be uh conservative upward 395.
how would you increase the value by 95
grand just by just by a
i mean in that 15 grand what are you
going to do that's going to be such a
transformational thing that's going to
push the value of that match
what i'm going to do is pick a complaint
because right now it's an illegal okay
okay so you're saying it's an illegal
hmo so they're sending it cheap because
they're obviously running it illegally
you would buy it you'd spend 15 grand
converting yet okay i like it good go
grab a seat who's next
lortan i'm very very very very i'm
shaking
at the moment so i feel like going back
in line i know yeah
so i'm not actually moving from here so
i'll stand here until everyone's looking
and i'll speak to some of myself in case
of
i don't understand don't try to shake
don't tell me to stand in front of you
and tell you something
if you know from the beginning that he
wasn't going to have me because i was
late
like that oh we didn't know you were
later you're late
at 3 30 yeah but if you said 3 to 3 30
and you turned up at 3 37 then
you're late
holy crap this guy's built like a fridge
and terrace in warrington okay i like it
i believe that we can get this
property for between eighty thousand
eighty five thousand
i took a build around there yesterday
wow good good action
we believe that the refurb cost is going
to be about
20 i've put in 25 just in case there's
anything else that i have not seen
so this is this is this is an actual
deal not like a lead
you've literally been out there with a
builder it's pretty close to be finished
yet
that's brilliant i've already spoke to
local agents three of them
and they've all confirmed that the rent
would be between 750 and 800.
did you know about brr had you done any
brrs or anything before this training
once i did the brr training it made me
realize how much it didn't know about it
okay so this is literally
straight off the back of your brr
training and you've found a deal you've
had a builder go out yeah
all right and and and it's on the market
for how much 125
125 and why do you think you could buy
it for 85
when it's on for 125. there's i've
already spoken to the vendor and built a
relationship up with her herself
and she's already given me the sort of
green light that she's a man he's got a
point
bevel bricks you do realize that there's
another four or five properties on for
125 they've all sold
they're selling like hot cakes in that
area okay
so how much are you going to spend on it
roughly i believe it's going to be about
20 000 when i budgeted 25 000.
okay and then the end value
after speaking to a couple of agents the
area is pushing in price going up so we
think that it's going to be about 135 to
140.
i can see that and the thing the thing
that i'm the most dubious about
late at lawton is the um is is the 20 is
the 85 grand
purchase price are you confident on that
yeah i'm pretty
pretty confident yeah i've spoken to uh
very good quite a few times
and all right i like it thank you i like
it
he was i was reciprocating exactly what
you love about the song
okay the same energy he was giving me
was the same energy i was giving back
do we like don't try and downplay public
transport because it does make a major
if you've got a car you can jump out and
do all this and that but then i've done
the
wonderful ones you've nodded and you're
checking in so what's the difference
because you don't care about it no no i
don't care about that but perhaps
if you value this opportunity that much
you would have come down this morning i
wish you well
i'm not here to argue simon's point he's
evicted and then gets out of my control
so i'm not here to i wish you completely
well
go ahead nadia let's hear what you got
okay i can see it it's on the market for
thirty thousand pound guide price
you know the difference between guy
price and reserve price and asking price
that's just the guideline to say it
could be more
how much more could it be i would say
less than double
no it's on for 30. so could it be 50
60 it could go up to 50. no but could it
so what's the result what's the reserve
price 30
you don't know that though
30 is the guide price yeah again i'm
having an i i'm sensing you don't know
the difference between the guide price
the reserve price and the purchase price
which is
fundamentally key in this did you do the
training
i did did you finish it not completely
almost how much did you finish it
because it's saying here that you did 20
because we have a tracker on it and how
is 20 almost finishing it
i didn't i didn't finish it okay but
many cases you almost finished it now
it's 20
did you just do 20. yes so
what do you think i'm going to say now
you're evicted
tell me about your deal i found the deal
in berlin okay
so so the end value is how much the n
value
i believe would be around 70 thousand
consecutive years seventy thousand
purchases five thousand so that's sixty
thousand all in
it's just like a cosmetic basically and
you're going to lift it up by ten
percent
yes i believe i believe i could say
seventy thousand
and with that at 5000. that's a very
high standard
not just the basic finish the training
good i mean
it's it's it's not a lot to ask
you know it's like it's brilliant
i've tried to go over a few more times
to really try to pause stuff and
understand
yeah because i want to make the most of
this more deal so what we've learned is
being a teacher's pet is a good thing
and will get you ahead in life
a lot of great people that will help me
sell the business where did you get the
the uh 70 000 gdv from literally just
looking on the market value of whatever
houses selling from the area
yeah what they're going for yeah i
believe i'll get housed to that standard
but better
yeah still over 70 000 so i believe
everything well them was consecutive
i didn't do it to a 70 000 pound market
but my house would be a lot better okay
cool yeah go grab a seat
enter it go ahead postcode cv2 good
area good part of coventry like it
you did the training right of course
because why would you not that would be
that would be crazy
okay cool tell me about the deal so the
asking price
what the landlord's asking for is 89 500
pounds he looks like if elijah wood and
jordan belfort had a love child
if i go to the salt properties
um would be between
well i've put 140 000 i've seen this
two bed properties sold like 21st of
february 2019 and property was sold
for 163 500. i've estimated the refurb
cost to be fifteen thousand
yeah and just so we can change uh change
up the kitchen
make it look modern and also
on the bedrooms they need to change the
flooring and
paint and decoration so
that would make it so the donut value is
140 000 the rent
i got an average of 575 pounds a month
how how is the n value 140 and it's just
sitting on right move 82 that doesn't
make any sense
well based on the figures that i've seen
on the property sold on the marks price
there's two beds going for two men
yeah they're going for the for one six
three one three one
yeah i can see that they are it's
strange
very strange but i guess you've just
found it now of course you've not done
all your due diligence on it
it looks on paper like a good deal so
yeah we'll investigate it okay cool go
grab a second
so that your next challenge is going to
be set tonight and there is going to be
more people evicted tomorrow
so i've just been evicted i feel like
it was fair because i didn't complete
all the online training
i feel like i would have gone a lot
further if i did do that
but yeah anyway i'm grateful for the
opportunity
um and i'm sure everyone will be seeing
me on winners on a wednesday very soon
i'm gonna get a month of coaching in the
month over that's what i'm grateful
about
[Music]
exactly and just show up just make sure
on the the weddings day calls you're
there
yeah um i i can tell you now
categorically that everyone comes on
that call they
realistically have 75 doing deals
to europe but even me
doing just a little bit has opened up my
mind
you know that i can do it yeah before i
was like how can i do it
coming up tomorrow i'm i'm stressed i'm
stressed
on their behalf i'm confident we're
going to win
you've got till then to sell that deal i
would recommend you sell it tonight and
you get the money in your bank
tonight hi guys i've just secured a deal
in warrington
two minutes to go why prolong the sale
tonight yeah and some of them already an
interest
that's huge they haven't got the hunger
that we got strong team
i don't know who's going to win this
this could go either which way so
i'm very sorry but you're evicted